fire stations big red trucks flashing
sirens that cool shiny pole well it all
dates back to colonial times and this
guy had a little something to do with it
that's right ben franklin
known for the constitution electricity
and the bifocals ben franklin had a
weird obsession with fire safety
on a trip to massachusetts franklin
noticed that the good people of boston
were much more fire savvy than his
fellow citizens in philadelphia hmm this
got ben thinking and he came up with the
idea to create a club or society of
active men belonging to each fire engine
whose business is to attend all fires
with it whenever they happen
then ben got weird he wrote an anonymous
letter to his own newspaper as a senior
citizen titled protections of towns from
fire dear pennsylvania gazette the
letter encouraged a better fire safety
plan and painted a horrifying
alternative people jumping out of
windows breaking their necks and being
burned alive
but it worked
in 1736 the first american volunteer
fire department was born the union fire
company it was comprised of 30
volunteers and you might know some of
them george washington thomas jefferson
and samuel adams that's right our
founding fathers were also firefighters
soon after fire companies and clubs
sprang up all over philadelphia and then
across the 13 colonies so thanks to the
matchless leadership of benjamin
franklin we now have firefighters
thanks ben
you